his gibbet then step at hmm today we're
gonna play with the iPad I have some
weird interesting games that we gonna
play you click on the videos you must be
kind of curious we're gonna start off
with of course snake fool MLG snake for
play at play okay
swipe to move go sanika
okay that was that game I really enjoyed
it I would rate it 10 out of 10 on IMDB
sway 36 I'm the pretty beat next game is
called llama or done quit
let's play time so [ __ ] you
fog duck duck llama and ugh [ __ ] see I'm
super short time how much fun ah ah
that's ridiculous
hey mama hello MA Jack Jack lamma lamma
lamma lamma lamma duck all walk
duck duck all that dark - wah wah wah
wah wah ah game and they do it mama -
mama mama turn turn
what's up
sexy there oh hello oh my god this is so
stressful oh man now
the next game is called Albert HD this
actually cost money so maybe it's not
actually chick
hi I bet how I grow all right this is
cool
um sleepyhead
turn on the alarm clocks as soon as
possible and I having fun absolutely
next game is called the coal of Duty get
it
alarians ever right I made it to level
39 play this game a lot this game is
awesome
the goal is to take a [ __ ] and you have
to find your way to the toilet without
running into man see I have to look at
the sides but you have very little time
it says yeah look at the arrow you look
at the arrow [ __ ] you [ __ ]
look at the signs ah yeah we can take
your [ __ ] press oh yeah oh the [ __ ] is
this got a terrace and mi a beer Jesus
Christ
all right so Knicks game is Raptor MMO
it's a game where you play as a raptor
with other fellow Raptors online it's
probably my favorite game of all time I
played around 600 hours in this game um
coconuts are great you can use them to
regain your stamina which of course will
make you faster in this game what all
you've got to do is collect DNA points
and DNA points might make you evolve
into a bigger Raptor in a sooner or
later we're going to attack this
standard a 69 try para pops fairly easy
kill just get in there gives us five DNA
points and they're in there a good farm
I mean we're starting up new levels so
they're there in parallel to level up
this Raptor great graphics in this game
it's gonna come out on Xbox one shoot it
would seem I know it's a big surprise
but literally no one else plays this
game it's not much of an MMO it's
literally just me being a raptor and I
add and just walk around here this is
what I do I'd said not that interesting
but uh I'm a raptor
that's it
next game is galactic kitties it is
exactly what it sounds like so we
control this space yarn and we collect
kitties with it oh god that kitties lost
forever in space that's kind of dark and
sad but we'll have to pretend that it
doesn't know now the portal opens we
need to make the kiddies go inside a
poem go inside a polar coos all right
well let's fish that attacks more
kitties goddammit goddammit watch out
for the asteroids is the portal going
Kitty's got my friends critics say this
is the greatest game of all time
and if you didn't think as galactic
kitties was good enough we have space
banana you heard me right folks space
banana
it's a banana in space and I'd a and all
you can do is be a banana in space what
is the point of anything
[ __ ] this alright well that it's also
fun for about five to ten seconds um
we're still watching no no this is great
say say with me it's gonna be great
right so you do this alright
you think you're gonna get a move but
now we got a snow globe what else you
think you're all we got an alligator
let's save that in the Box is alright
and I just
all right guys
it seems that porch has had a mental
breakdown uh again so I'm just gonna
have to end this video for him they
leave a like to save the life of a space
banana and I will see you Rose um in the
next video alright bro brofist ah so
nice I'm so glad I can relive this if
you for experience inside a video game
oh there's my sexy body
alright I know you can Crouch in this
game unless there it is and there's a
poop